Let's see how we would do this in BlueJ. Here's the loop that we had before,
which used zero to decide when to quit, but now we want to go as long as
there's another double. We can use the hasNextDouble method to ask the scanner
if the next token it has is a double. Then we basically want to do the same
stuff as before, right, asking for input and adding it to the sum in counting.
Let's just try this. Hm, still running, still running. Okay, I think there's a
bug here. So, let's stop this. Look at the code again. Where could this have
got stuck? I've never seen simple variable assignments like this get stuck
before. So, I think that's not the problem. Now, here I check if there's
another double. Oh, there isn't another double, because I haven't asked for one
yet. So, I'll need to ask the user for a double before I check if there is
another double. And now, I'll have to ask again somewhere in the loop. I don't
want to ask immediately because then I'll ask twice. So, I probably want to ask
at the end, after I process the value I already asked for. Let's test this
again. I can enter three, and four, and zero. Well, it looks like this message
isn't right yet. But, if I add a q then I get my average back. That's
interesting. This is the average of only the first two numbers, it didn't
include the zero, I guess we're still not there yet. We're only incrementing
the count if the value is not zero.
[LAUGH]
We've also got this cruft with the done, we're not going to need that anymore.
So, I'll take out everything associated with done. Now, let's see. We have the
user enter something If it's a number, we read it in, add it to the sum, count,
and ask for another one. This is probably what we wanted. Now, if I enter
three, four, and zero, that's better.